calculating the odds of winning in nan
combat just shows how you're missing the
point
you've never know what your adversaries
ability is but I have yet to meet anyone
with an ability more flexible than my
deep purple hello and welcome to hunter
hunt of 101 the series that breaks down
everyone and everything in the Hunter
hunter world and today we are going to
be investigating one of the most
experienced modern-day hunters in the
series Laurel McCune se Maroma Canarsie
is a single star sea hunter who was
first introduced during the Chimera ant
Ark as part of the extermination team
morale is best characterized by his
exceedingly calm and patient nature as
well as his strong leadership skills and
tactical genius within the realm of
combat but despite this outward
characterization morale is also highly
emotional and possesses a solid sense of
compassion although he keeps outside of
him very much in check making moral a
well-balanced individual within this
incredibly insane world as I see hunter
morals focus lies in the deep depths of
the world seeking out general treasure
or rare animals and while we don't know
the specifics of his accomplishments in
this field he has been awarded a single
star as a result of his actions as a
hunter furthermore morale is renowned
enough to have taken on two students
being not combined and shoot Pokemon
both of whom are highly accomplished
hunters in their own right and
furthermore morale is one of only two
hunters trusted enough by Chairman
iturra to accompany him into the neo
green life autonomous region to carry
out the extermination with the chimera
ants and just briefly on hunter politics
in terms of the Association Mora was a
stout supporter of notorious camp
holding a profound level of respect for
him and in contrast Maul despises the
power-hungry faction led by parastone
hill seeing him as a dishonorable schema
who is willing to sacrifice anyone and
anything to achieve whatever it is that
he desires something that certainly does
not agree with morals more compassionate
nature but that said the moral that we
would come to know was not the one that
the audience was first introduced to as
upon entering in jail Mora would come
into contact with gon and killua which
would show us a surprisingly arrogant
side to the hunter who proceeded to
taunt kilwa and completely dismiss his
concerns regarding the threat that they
were about to face however in this
moment morale did provide his own
personal philosophy regarding non combat
which boils down to the fact that you
can never know what your opponent's
ability is and that you must always
fight like you are 100% certain you can
win and that sense of confidence most
certainly carried over into the ensuing
battles that we were treated to
featuring morale
his exceptional known abilities in terms
of that moral is a manipulator with a
proficiency in the further areas of
enhancement emission and transmutation
latter of which being very impressive as
it is the error in which manipulator
possesses the lowest natural affinity
for however in order to enact his
abilities moral requires the catalyst of
a giant tobacco pipe and through this
medium moral is able to initiate a
hatsune in his deep purple which
requires moral to transmute his aura
into smoke and go on to manipulate that
smoke in any way he deems necessary and
he can for all intents and purposes
essentially create anything such as
ropes grass or even adorable little
bunnies but he is of course also capable
of crafting much more complex beings one
example of which are the smoke troopers
with the addition of a mission moral is
able to part with a corps of aura which
contains manipulation commands simple
commands that is like whether or not to
attack defend or retreat when
encountering an enemy and very
interestingly smoke troopers with this
emitter core actually indistinguishable
from regular humans via the use of n
making them very versatile especially
since they are capable of mimicking
humans aesthetically as well all in all
Marlowe's capable of crafting and
controlling 216 smoke troopers at any
given time however at that maximum
number they aren't very limited in terms
of commands so in the case of requiring
something with a bit more complexity
morale can compress this number of
troopers down to 50 sacrificing quantity
for some of that good old quality
however something to be very wary of is
the fact that invoking deep purple costs
aura that morale loses access to until
his creations are dispelled which can
leave him individually quite vulnerable
however morale does possess at least one
other heart - in which to engage with
known as smoky Jail in which he encases
himself and an opponent with a seemingly
impenetrable prison of smoke strong
enough that even a chimera ant Royal
Guard would not be able to penetrate it
however due to the fact that it is smoke
it does allow particle sized entities to
pass through it which will become
important in a bit but in regards to
aura itself unlike many characters in
the series we actually have a fairly
accurate measure of how much moral is
able to output which according to his
disciple knuckle lands at some might
around 70,000 or a units and for some
comparison knuckle also managed to
measure Gong's output which did not even
amount to a third of morals sitting at
twenty one thousand five hundred units
in facts knuckle has claimed that moral
possesses the most abundant Oracle that
he has ever seen but this was of course
prior to engaging in combat with the
Chimera ant Royal Guards and it's also
highly unlikely that knuckle would have
had the opportunity to
we measure many of the world's most
powerful hunters so you know take that
as you will
now having briefly brought up gone again
it must be said that despite his
relative inexperience morale was always
confident that gun would excel in true
combat and become a great asset to the
extermination team whereas his disciples
on the other hand had their extreme
doubts as a result more pretended to
express his verbal doubts and challenge
gone to hit him with everything he's got
to earn his place on the extermination
team to which gone wasted no time
whatsoever summoning up a judge Hunkin
the sheer power of which as well as the
bloodlust emanating from gone sent
morale into a cold sweat but before the
attack could strike morale gone was
stopped by kilwa however by this time
Maral had completed his task as the
other hunters present were able to
witness guns determination firsthand now
as a member of the extermination team
morale faced a wide array of challenges
over the course of the Chimera ant arc
quite notably engaging in combat with
chi - which perfectly displayed morals
aforementioned philosophy of non combat
as his confidence range throughout the
fight Argus miraculous should have been
called a test of wills perhaps even
patience this is because morale was
caught in a han-soo known as tag whereby
Chi - conjured an artificial namespace
where both he and Mara would be stuck
for eight hours with the only way to
exit earlier being morale meeting the
condition of touching chi - something of
an impossibility considering his speed
so in response morale just sort of laid
down and pretended to go to sleep
starting a series of events that would
seem or replacing himself for the smokey
clone eventually allowing him to give to
you - a gentle tap on the shoulder and
thus winning the game Mara would also
come face to face with they all who had
a quiet and inability that allowed him
to conjure and manipulate vast amounts
of water however being a sea hunter Mara
was perfectly equipped to deal with this
using his exceptional lung capacity to
submerge himself and create a hose out
of smoke proceeding to exhale and fill
the surface of the closed off fighting
arena with carbon dioxide which
eventually poisoned and killed AO to top
it all off during the palace invasion
Morel was assigned to deal with the
Royal Guard Shia poof whom he
successfully encased in a smoky Jail
however Shia poof then performed a
gambit by enveloping himself in a cocoon
and proceeding to scatter himself into
the form of trillions of microscopic
beings and slipped through the smoky
Jail bit by bit and on this occasion
morale was outwitted choosing to
deactivate smoky jail only to be
ambushed and have his trademark pipe
stolen away from him leaving him unable
to engage in his heart's ooh any further
and without the ability to create new
smoke troopers morale was limited to the
eighty nine remaining constructs that he
had previously crafted as he entered
into a battle against another world
guard by the name of u P who went on to
easily dispatched smoke creations and
heavily wounded morale although Morrow
would be saved by his disciple knuckle
who struck a deal with u P to save him
but in the process remove any chance the
extermination team and had of defeating
you P Morrel who was prepared to die to
ensure the excess of the mission was
then taken away by Nava but not before
chastising his disciple and thus ending
his involvement in the palace invasion
after the death of the ant king Mora was
the one who made the mission report
directly to beans and he then turned his
focus to helping Gaughan recover as over
the course of the arc morrel's initial
arrogance towards gon and killua had
long since subsided and morphed into a
great level of respect for their pure
determination as hunters duty as valor
in the extermination mission it has also
been said that morale may have been
awarded with a triple star license and
he was even thrown in as a candidate to
become 13th chairman of the hunter
Association however during the election
morels candidacy never built any
particular momentum and it is later
confirmed that Maura was not in any way
interested in the idea of becoming the
next chairman however his candidacy
persisted due to the nomination process
which does not require the consent of
the hunter in question to be put forward
in fact during the election process role
was in hospital recovering from his
encounter with the chimera ants and
focusing all of his efforts on
facilitating Dawn's recovery despite
this morals name made it all the way to
the fifth round of voting however it had
been pushed off the shortlist of
candidates
by the sixth round but morals efforts
would lead to great success as
eventually kill Allah was able to reach
gone with a locker and use their
incredible power to heal him quite
notably it should be said that morale
was completely shocked by the power he
felt at this time and considering that
he had very recently had his fill of
feeling tremendous aura at the hands of
the chimera ants this would not have
been an easy feat to achieve but hey
that's the power of the Dark Continent
for you and speaking of most recently
due to his experience as a sea hunter
morale has taken up the role of
navigator for the expedition to the Dark
Continent
which I'm sure we'll get to you know one
day some more fun facts about morale
despite having developed a smoking based
hearts ooh morale is more than likely
not an actual smoker himself as he has
never been seen engaging in the act of
smoking that wasn't for the process of
turning his aura into smirk according to
the hunter and Emanuel
morale scores an amazing four out of
five in the areas of mind body skill nan
and intelligence in fact the only sector
in which he did not achieve this was
ingenuity in which he only scored a
three out of five which I would
personally argue with given that morale
is one of the most creative and
versatile individuals that we have ever
seen in hunter hunter but what can you
do due to his habit of always wearing
sunglasses even at night morals eyes
have never been seen in the series
although it is interesting to note that
he entered NGO with the sunglasses
given that they classify as a contraband
substance under the rules of the nation
although as some of you suggested in my
video about Nava this could have been
due tomorrow placing them in novice
hide-and-seek ability for the duration
of time it took them to cross the border
morals full name is an anagram like
reference I say anagram like because it
isn't perfect but it is a reference to a
Japanese author by the name of Ramona
Kojima who is a famed cult novel author
known for living a particularly wild
life incorporating staggering amounts of
drugs and alcohol but more importantly
he also often wore sunglasses the
references don't stop there though as
morals deep purple heart sue has a
wealth of musical notes within it the
first of which being that it was named
after the English rock band deep purple
furthermore the kanji for the technique
goes on to reference the song Purple
Haze by Jimi Hendrix and smokey jails
alternate name jailhouse rock is of
course a reference to Elvis Presley song
of the same name and finally a truly
useless fact in the manga after having
been saved from UPB knuckle morale
proceeds to flip him off but that pretty
much does it for morale if you enjoyed
this video and the content this channel
produces in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next hunter 101
you